>> Jesse: RETIREMENT IS NOT FOR
EVERYONE.
SOME PEOPLE JUST NEED TO STAY
BUSY.
THEY DON'T LIKE PLAYING GOLF.
THEY JUST LIKE TO MOSEY AROUND
LOOKING FOR STUFF TO DO.
THAT'S WHERE BARACK OBAMA IS
RIGHT NOW.
I GUESS THE PODCAST AND NETFLIX
DEALS ARE ENOUGH TO OCCUPY
BARRY'S TIME.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS TO STAY
BUSY.
HE HAS BEEN OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
HE HAS BEEN POPPING UP ON
SPEAKING TOURS AND HITTING THE
AIRWAVES TO LECTURE US ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, THE LIES.
>> IT'S JUST THIS NATIONAL STORY
THAT IS BEING TOLD WHERE WE
ALLOW LIES TO BE TOLD AND WE
ACCEPT THEM AND SO WE ENJOY THE
PERFORMATIVE ASPECTS OF MAKING
STUFF UP.
AND PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE WE
DON'T THINK THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES TO IT.
>> Jesse: I GUESS MICHELLE HAS A
BOOK OUT NOW SO BARACK IS
FEELING A LITTLE LONELY AT HOME
AND NEEDS TO GET OUT ON THE TOWN
AND GET A LITTLE ATTENTION.
IS HE DOING A LITTLE P.R. BLITZ.
IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT HIM AND HIS
LEGACY AND HOW BARRY FEELS AND
HOW HE IS A VIRTUOUS
TRUTH-TELLER CRUSADING AGAINST
LYING BIGOTS.
I KNOW, I KNOW, WE HAVE BEEN
HEARING THIS NOR YEARS.
NO ONE LIED LIKE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY JUST GOT AWAY WITH IT
BECAUSE CALLING OBAMA IS A LIAR
IS CONSIDERED RACIST.
>> IF YOU LIKE YOUR DOCTOR, CAN
YOU KEEP YOUR DOCTOR.
IF YOU LIKE YOUR HEALTHCARE
PLAN, YOU CAN KEEP YOUR
HEALTHCARE PLAN.
>> THAT'S A RED LINE FOR US.
AND THAT THERE WOULD BE ENORMOUS
CONSEQUENCES IF WE START SEEING
MOVEMENT ON THE CHEMICAL WEAPONS
FRONT.
>> THERE IS NO SPYING ON
AMERICANS.
YOU KNOW, WE DON'T HAVE A
DOMESTIC SPYING PROGRAM.
>> Jesse: OBAMA LIED LOST YOUR
DOCTOR.
LOST WATCHED GENOCIDE AND LIED
ABOUT HOW MUCH HE SPIED.
HE LIED ABOUT THE IRS, BENGALS,
FAST AND FURIOUS.
HE LIED WHEN HE SAID HILLARY WAS
LIKEABLE AND JOE BIDEN DIDN'T
LEARN MUCH FROM BEING NUMBER 2
TO BARRY BUT HIS ADMINISTRATION
DID LEARN ONE THING.
THAT LYING IS THE BEST STRATEGY
BECAUSE THE MEDIA LETS YOU DO
IT.
>> THE ECONOMISTS THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN RELYING ON
SUGGEST THAT THERE IS A
TRANSITORY NATURE TO THE
INFLATION.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID AND
YOU HAVE TWEETED THAT
ALLEGATIONS OF WRONGDOING BASED
ON FILES PULLED FROM HUNTER
BIDEN'S LAPTOP ARE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
>> IT'S BROADLY KNOWN AND WIDELY
KNOWN, PETER THERE WAS A BROAD
RANGE OF RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
BACK IN 2020.
>> SECRETARY MAYORKAS, DO YOU
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THAT THE
BORDER IS SECURE?
>> YES.
>> Jesse: BUT THIS IS WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS DO.
THEY PUSH YOU DOWN AND THEN THEY
SAY YOU FELL.
THE BORDER IS SECURE, INFLATION
IS ZERO.
THE REPUBLICANS DEFUNDED THE
POLICE.
AND I NEVER EVER TALK TO MY SON
ABOUT HIS OVERSEAS BUSINESS
DEALS.
SO, OBAMA'S LEGACY GAVE US
DONALD TRUMP BUT THEN IT GAVE US
JOE BIDEN.
SO, AS BARACK SITS HOME ALONE
WHILE MICHELLE MAKES MILLIONS
OFF HER BOOK THAT NO ONE HAS
READ, THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS
STARTED TO FIGURE OUT THAT NO
ONE REALLY LIKES HIM AS MUCH AS
HE THINKS.
SO HE HAS TO TELL HIMSELF IT'S
NOT HIS FAULT THAT PEOPLE DON'T
LIKE HIM.
IT'S FOX'S FAULT.
>> THE BIGGEST CHANGE THAT'S
TAKEN PLACE, WHEN I RAN FOR,
LET'S SAY, U.S. SENATE IN
ILLINOIS, I COULD GO TO A DINER
OR A VFW HALL OR COUNTY FAIR.
I COULD GO TO THE LOCAL
NEWSPAPER AND THE OWNER THERE IS
CONSERVATIVE AND HE HAS GOT A
BOW TIE AND BUZZ CUT.
IS HE KIND OF SUBSEQUENT CALL
ABOUT MY IDEAS.
THERE WASN'T THE FILTER THAT HAD
BEEN FOX NEWS OR THE MEDIA
INFRASTRUCTURE THE RIGHT WING
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THE FILTER NOW HAS BECOME SO
THICK IT STARTED, I THINK, WITH
FOX NEWS.
>> Jesse: SO THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS IN RETIREMENT YOU START
GOING OVER IN YOUR HEAD LIKE
WHAT HAPPENED TELLING YOURSELF
WELL, THINGS COULD HAVE BEEN
DIFFERENT IF ONLY THIS GUY
WASN'T THERE OR THIS GUY WASN'T
THERE.
HEARING A GROWN MAN TALK ABOUT
OTHER PEOPLE NOT LYING HIM IS
KIND OF WEIRD.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THAT MAN IS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
I MEAN, SOME PEOPLE LIKED HIM,
OBVIOUSLY.
AND WHY IS OBAMA SO FIXATED ON
FOX NEWS?
AND WHY DOES HE HAVE SUCH THIN
SKIN?
NED RYUN IS THE FOUNDER OF
AMERICAN MAJORITY AND HE JOINS
ME NOW.
SO WHAT IS GOING ON?
THIS SEEMS ALMOST LIKE IS HE
SITTING DOWN ON SHRINK'S COUCH,
NED.
>> WELL, THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
TRUE, JESSE.
IT'S ALSO A REMINDER BLESSED ONE
THAT CAME TO BRING SALVATION TO
THIS COUNTRY AND HOW DARE YOU
QUESTION HIS MOTIVE.
OF COURSE, HE WAS AN AMAZING
LIAR.
HIS, IF YOU LIKE YOUR HEALTHCARE
PLAN YOU CAN KEEP YOUR
HEALTHCARE PLAN WAS ACTUALLY THE
LIE OF THE YEAR, ACCORDING TO
POLITIFACT AND IF I WAS ACTUALLY
TO RECITE BACK TO YOU ALL OF HIS
LIES WE WOULD EAT UP THE REST OF
THE SHOW.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO DO IT.
THE THING THAT'S AMAZING ABOUT
OBAMA AS HE IS LECTURING US
ABOUT LIES HE IS REPRESENTING A
PARTY THAT BELIEVES BOYS CAN
BECOME GIRLS.
THAT THERE ARE 73 GENDERS, THAT
CRIME IS A SOCIAL CONSTRUCT THAT
MAN MADE GLOBAL WARMING IS REAL.
THAT VEGETABLES CAN BECOME
SENATORS, ACTUALLY, THAT ONE IS
TRUE.
BUT WHERE THE LEFT IS RIGHT NOW
IS THEY WANT US TO ACCEPT THEIR
INSANITY AS TRUTH AND OPINIONS
AS DOGMAS AND WHEN YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE THE TEMERITY TO QUESTION
IT, SAY WHAT ARE THE ORIGINS OF
COVID, THEY CAN'T EVEN STAND
THOSE QUESTIONS AND WANT TO
CENSOR IT BECAUSE, IN FACT, THEY
ARE AUTHORITARIANS AND THE
NARRATIVE IS ALL NOT FACTS NOT
TRUTH THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AT
RIGHT NOW.
THE DIRTY LITTLE PEASANTS NEED
TO SHUT DOWN AND SHUT UP AND
LISTEN TO THEIR BET BETTERS IF
YOU WANT ANY ELM PATRIARCHAL
COMMENTS ON FOX BUT LOOK HOW THE
LEFT HAS LOST ITS MIND WHEN ELON
MUSK DARED TO SUGGEST AND IS
TRYING TO TURN TWITTER INTO A
FREE SPEECH PLATFORM WHICH, OH,
BY THE WAY IS JUST LIVING OUT
THE FIRST AMENDMENT AS OUR BILL
OF RIGHTS ACTUALLY STATES.
BUT THE LEFT CAN'T HANDLE THAT.
>> Jesse: THEY CAN'T HANDLE THAT
AND THEY CAN'T HANDLE FOX
BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY CALL HIM OUT
ON THEIR LIES.
AND BOMBER THINKS THE WORLD
WOULD BE PERFECT AND HE WOULD BE
LOVED BY 100 PERCENT OF THE
COUNTRY IF WEREN'T FOR FOX NEWS.
I HATE TO BREAK IT TO YOU,
BARRY, PEOPLE DIDN'T LIKE YOU
BEFORE FOX, THEY A